okay why don't we get started thank you
everyone is as most of you know I
usually introduce the speaker so i will
introduce the speaker which happens to
be me even though I'm the speaker even
though I'm the department here I'm
always worried if everyone's going to if
anyone's going to show up so I
appreciate you coming to listen to me so
as all of you who have been here know
that during the academic year we have
our weekly conference on Thursdays and
sometimes for one reason or another we
may not have it other times it may get
moved like for example we have another
speaker coming tomorrow because Friday's
the day that he happens to be available
so sometimes people come at different
times but we do try to have this
conference each week and sometimes we
designate the conference as an IDL talk
and informatics discovery lab which I'll
talk briefly about X I guess starting
next year these occasional meetings of
these conferences will be our clinical
informatics grand rounds but they'll all
be open to everyone and will encourage
people to come as the fellows and
faculty know we expect attendance at
these conferences and we do though
stream them so there is some number of
people out there listening and the
streaming is mainly for people who who
can't be on campus so people who are our
distance learning students or other
people either locally around portland or
beyond can come to can can still take
part in our conference we have a hashtag
d mice come
that people can tweet in questions at us
and so we usually designate a recipient
so I think Deb is either on her phone or
computer and actually have my phone here
on Twitter if all else fails so I
thought and I've done this
intermittently over time but I thought
maybe be good to to do it at the
beginning of each year to give an
overview of where I see the field going
and the program going it's it's just
well it's not opinion I actually try to
cite things but it's just my view of
where things are and I will try to leave
a little time for QA people want to add
things embellish things disagree with me
then well happy to have you happy to
have that so I guess by way of
introduction most of you know me on my
bill Hirsch I'm the head of the
department I can actually now add
another to my two long list of
designations a diplomat in clinical
informatics from the American Board of
preventive medicine and I'll talk a
little bit about the just a very little
bit because it's only a small part of
the larger informatics universe about
the new sub specialty for physicians as
always my slides are in a PDF with all
my references cited on my website and as
you know I I like to blog and take
advantage of other social media so the
agenda for today is to give kind of an
update overview of the state of the
field to launch the conference series as
I've already mentioned about attendance
expectations we also have a vanity URL
so there's no longer that long URL that
to get to the streaming so we'll we'll
find out the statistics afterwards how
many people are actually listening and
people should tweet
with the hashtag that can also tweet to
our main Twitter account okay so what
about the state of the field well I
really honestly believe that the field
has really changed tremendously in the
last five years or so there's been a
number of things not the least of which
has been the HITECH Act but informatics
really is different now than it was I
was talking to someone yesterday I've
actually worked in this building now for
24 years or twenty three years I've been
here for 24 years and actually in a
couple years I saw Chris out there we're
going to be celebrating our 25-year
anniversary of the building but really
there have been some profound events in
informatics that have really changed
things probably most significant just
maybe in terms of the sheer number of
dollars has been the HITECH Act the 30
billion dollar investment in electronic
health records but it's not limited the
clinical informatics the continued
accuracy and reduced cost of sequencing
and probably even more important that
translation into clinical medicine of
the CTSA program the clinical and
translational science reward program
which has really galvanized the area of
clinical research informatics the
patient-centered outcomes Institute or P
Cory that is funded actually by
Obamacare and it's providing hundreds of
millions of dollars of investment
including these new clinical data
research networks and there's new
developments in the offing will I can
share a little news although were were
semi embargoed from NIH talking about
the big data to knowledge program of
which we've been awarded some grants and
also other work going on for example on
bringing informatics to clinicians and
clinical education so you all know some
of many of you've seen this slide or
variants of this slide
in in 2009 when the American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act was introduced
there was the part of it that put up to
27 billion or really about 30 billion
dollars for adoption of electronic
health records including the awarding of
grants and a two billion dollar
investment including 118 million for
Workforce 5.8 million of which came to
this department and those were the those
were the golden days a few years ago but
that that that money's all gone although
we've managed to continue on since then
and it's had a significant impact most
hospitals now ninety-four percent have
an electronic health record although not
all of them use it as with as much
functionality as they could over three
quarters of us physicians use electronic
health records I those of you who have
taken five ten have seen the other
graphs about how much the u.s. is a
laggard but the u.s. is actually
catching up now in just in terms of
adoption and this provides other
opportunities that many of us are
interested in myself included it various
secondary use of clinical data whether
it's personal health records quality
measurement predictive analytics
clinical and translational research
public health surveillance ultimately
supporting this notion of the learning
health system unlike many other
industries in healthcare we we don't do
a good job of learning from what we do
and part of the reason why we
historically haven't done that well
because we wrote things down on paper
and never saw it again other than maybe
when the patient came back but we have
opportunities for these things though
there's lots of challenges there's also
a growing evidence base there's you know
controversy about what evidence supports
the value of health information
technology
there's various listservs that Amy runs
that have debates about this topic but
if you look at the scientific evidence
base for the efficacy of health
information technology whether you look
at it by category of what the health IT
is starting trying to do or even break
it into the meaningful use criteria
there is evidence that supports health
information technology the problem the
problem is that it's been challenging
translating that efficacy into
effectiveness efficacy being the
evaluation of something in very
controlled situations effectiveness
being you know putting it out there for
the world to try and so there's a lot of
challenges and we heard earlier this
week from dr. Robert wah the president
of the AMA who pointed to this report
that was commissioned by the AMA last
year they looked at things causing
dissatisfaction and in the work of
physicians and EHRs electronic health
records was right up there at the top
there was also a study in a magazine
medical economics that surveyed
physicians about electronic health
records and complaints about their poor
functionality their high costs all of
the emphasis on meaningful use meeting
those criteria so they could get the
incentive funding and there was just a
study a few weeks ago it was by Clem
McDonald some of you know it was
unfortunately it was sexy a full study
and jama made them compress it down to a
research letter so they had to leave a
lot of things out but basically they
asked the large number of internal
medicine physicians various questions
about electronic health records and the
the soundbite that came out of it is
that sixty percent of them reported
electronic health records increasing
their time now you could put a more
positive spin on that say well for forty
percent of them actually something like
twenty three percent said
actually save them time others were
neutral but clearly there are aspects of
electronic health records especially
when they're not implemented properly
that do slow people down and impede
their workflow there's also concerns
about safety I they're important and we
can't sweep them under the rug although
we also have to remember all the other
issues about safety in healthcare safety
related to paper records and the fact
that records get lost errors get made
and there's no chance with things like
clinical decision support to fix them
and this has led to the safer guides
that Joan and others in the field have
produced to help lead to say poor
implementation and there's also the
concern about the lack of adherence we
have all these electronic health records
but they don't talk to each other there
are standards to do that there are
interoperability standards there was a
report by this group called Jason which
is this group of scientists that the
government Commission's to do various
reports lamenting that we haven't
achieved the the promise of electronic
health records in part because we have
not enforced standards as well as we
could and I wrote in my blog a few weeks
ago pointing to a couple examples of
situations i've been in we're
essentially people spend a lot of time
and effort unscrambling eggs when you
take for example a laboratory report
pull it out of a database print it in a
document print that document on a piece
of paper and turn it into a scanned PDF
and then actually talking about hiring
someone to OCR that PDF back to the data
you know back to the discrete data
elements which to me I think probably
most of you is seems like a waste of
money anyway so we still even though
we've had widespread adoption there's
still a lot of challenges that we face
meanwhile there has also been lots of
advances in genomics bioinformatics all
the related areas dr. wah from the AMA
also showed this slide which shows how
the cost of sequencing genomes has come
down faster than Moore's Law for a while
it was adhering to Moore's law and now
it's been even faster although it's
tapered off a little bit and who knows
whether that's a trend or not but aiming
for this thousand-dollar genome goal and
many believe that once we reach that
thousand dollar goal that it will be
something that we can do on ordinary
people and I think for those of us who
work in medical centers the real
excitement about gene sequencing and
uncovering genomic variants and
identifying phenotypes associated with
them is the ability to actually use that
information in an actionable way Shannon
mcqueeney always talks about the
importance of genomic information being
actionable and probably the project that
has done the most with this some of you
are familiar with the emerge project
that the E&M stand for electronic
medical records and this paper was
published recently that listed out all
of the areas where finding from the
emerge project has actually led to some
clinically actionable information some
of them are being implemented in
clinical decision support rules and
electronic health records their table
lists about can't remember the number 80
or so of these genomic markers that in
various diseases and conditions and so
forth so we're actually reaching the
point where the genomics bioinformatics
is is really translating into clinical
medicine and I think that that's
and exciting advance this also raises a
lot of issues for electronic health
records dan Macy's who has been here
from time to time some of you know him
has talked about what we're going to
need to do to electronic health records
when we have this genomic information in
actionable formats how much of it goes
into the medical record itself how much
of it goes into other systems what do we
do when even if the the genome is static
when we learn something about a new
variant that's associated with a disease
or with the response to treatment will
you know how do we update the medical
record how do we maybe get that
information to the clinician I there's
there's a lot of unsolved issues but
those unsolved issues are potentially
interesting research projects for people
to take on and another person who's
written about this some of you know
Justin star in talking about again what
do we put in the electronic health
record what goes into these ancillary
systems and how they interact with each
other and that's a ripe area especially
for programs that are strong in both
clinical informatics and bioinformatics
just some of the other drivers that
we've seen in of informatics it's older
than five years it's actually more like
about eight or nine years old now but
the CTSA program clinical and
translational science award which are
awards to 60 or so academic medical
centers including ohsu in fact we were
actually funded in the very first round
and this it's been clear from the get-go
xai should have put this in my slide but
the original RFA request for
applications use the word informatics
something like 30 times informatics is a
very important component of the CTSA
program until recently actually I served
as director of our informatics program
within
CTSA were ohs us in the process of
hiring a chief research informatics
officer who will assume that role in Rob
shop in the interim is filling that role
but that one thing that the CTSA program
has done is facilitated these clinical
data repositories this paper by McKenzie
who actually works for one of our former
graduates Peter at u-dub anyways many
institutions now are pulling data out of
their electronic health record into
these data repositories some data more
than others things like problem list
demographics it's like ninety-five
percent down to things like orders is
more like twenty percent but most
research oriented medical centers are
creating these big data repositories
data warehouses that provide
opportunities for research and other
things related informatics and really
the CTSA program has galvanized this
whole area of clinical research
informatics many a number of faculty
myself Judy Logan others who have been
involved in clinical research
informatics i mentioned p corey at the
beginning this is another opportunity
they've had a lot of focus on on methods
and one of the big activities of P Corey
are these clinical research data
networks that were rolled out in in
different places around the country
there is one in Oregon some of you might
be familiar with ocean and they're
collaborating with others and so these
clinical research data networks or CDR
ends will start to collect large amounts
of information on large numbers of
people large amounts of data and then
there's new opportunities coming down
the pike big data which depending on the
day i think is hype or is really
important
but I think this whole related area and
unfortunately just like with informatics
with all of our different labels of
informatics you know clinical medical
bio etc this field has this as well
because some people talk about data
analytics data science they're they're
all interrelated but I i I'm not the
only person others noted i remember a
couple years ago when people started
asking me well what are the
opportunities going to be in clinical
informatics when we're done implementing
electronic health records are there
going to be any jobs left to do and i
said actually that's when the
interesting work is going to start will
actually be able to do interesting
things with this data actually improve
health care improve people's health and
so forth many people have thought about
clinical data I with some colleagues a
couple years ago wrote or last year
wrote some papers about some of the
caveats and the opportunities and NIH
has recognized this area as well and we
have been awarded so i can say that in
public but nih just doesn't yet want us
to say a real lot there next week
they're going to announce the whole bd2k
program the funding of the big centers
but we were awarded a couple grants that
one is on development of open
educational materials somewhat similar
some of you are familiar with the
project one of the big projects we had
with the hitech act with the development
of the health IT curriculum in fact our
grant actually proposed to use that
exact same format to in essence add big
data materials to the ONC health IT
curriculum so we've been funded to do
that and then also myself but David door
Melissa handle Shannon also funded to
develop a skills course that I'm sure
will be of interest to too many of you
so you'll hear more about that going
forward and importantly informatics
takes p
ball and there have been tremendous
opportunities and I'm confident that
there will continue to be there does not
appear to be any abatement in the growth
and this is actually an area of interest
because I started asking around
2005-2006 as our educational programs
were going what are the needs and there
no one had documented anything and that
led sometimes your studies that get
cited the most and get the most
attention are not what you would
consider to be your best science i did
this relatively simple analysis of but
finding as you go to the higher hymns
stage of adoption that there's actually
more need for health IT professionals
and we actually estimated 41,000 would
be needed as we started implementing
things like clinical decision support
and computerized provider order entry I
think I can actually say with a straight
face that this had some influence of
that little section 30 16 of the HITECH
Act that put money into health IT
workforce development in fact senator
Wyden Ron Wyden from Oregon and his
staff were instrumental in adding that
part to the bill and I had a few phone
conversations and that's the only place
in the entire hitech act where the word
informatics occurs so I think we were
success but the and the interesting
thing is that we actually were wrong we
underestimated I'll show you on the next
slide the it's actually more like about
60,000 that the growth of jobs in health
IT and these are well-paying jobs there
was just a report that came out from
this website health IT jobs com and if
you look at the different types of jobs
and the salaries that they pay one can
make a good living doing informatics and
and that's important for us you guys are
spending your your time and some of you
your money in our educational program
and we hope that will be a good
investment and I think the data points
in that direction and in fact there XE
are still shortages there was a well
sited study from chime and organization
of healthcare CIOs in 2012 that said 71
percent had staff shortages that could
jeopardize a project and fifty-eight
percent said that that would affect
their ability to meet the meaningful use
criteria and qualify for those incentive
dollars and hims has continued to do
these work for surveys and pretty much
the same kind of picture many
organizations are planning to hire and
they're concerned about shortages and
not only healthcare organizations but
also vendors most of this is in clinical
informatics but in i think in other
areas of informatics too we've seen no
lack of interest in people who want to
hire including hiring our graduates so
this is the figure i like to show that
it would be nice if this were updated
because it only goes to 2011 but between
when i published my study and 2011 and i
don't really know how to explain that
little dip but the point is that i feel
good to say that we underestimated the
number of people who would be hired into
health IT jobs just a few comments about
the physician sub-specialty about thirty
percent of our students are physicians
so and I'm one myself so it it's an
important area most of you know the
story it started in 2009 when a mia put
forth a proposal to the American Board
of Medical Specialties calling for a
sub-specialty of all medical specialties
some might have hoped that it would just
become its own specialty but that that's
a really politically difficult thing to
do but in any case some a mia put forth
our curriculum training requirements and
in 2011 it was approved there are many
different specialty boards the American
Board of preventive med
step forward and said will be the home
administrative home for this but again
it's a specialty of it's a sub specialty
of all specialties last year the first
certification exam was awkward I'll talk
about the qualifications in the next
slide and ninety-one percent of people
past including a couple of us in this
room and can now say that were
board-certified I probably would have
been embarrassed if I had not passed the
test but I actually can say that a at
their of these 455 about 40 of them are
either graduates or current students in
our program and actually I feel good
about this several that Maxie scored
higher than I did so they did well and
we prepared them well and then this year
when you start moving into this medical
specialty sub specialty kind of model
you start getting into all of the ways
that medical training is done which is
different from graduate school and we're
sort of used to more of a graduate
school model but the Accreditation
Council for graduate medical education
released its rules and actually we found
out just last week that we're now the
third program in the country to receive
initial accreditation and we'll be
starting i'll mention that a little bit
and the slide after this but just a few
details about the sub specialty
typically when there's a new medical
specialty or sub specialty there's
already people that have been practicing
in that area and so there's this
grandfathering period where you don't
have to do formal training if you do
enough practice so if you practice
informatics 25% time within the last
five years or do what they call a
non-traditional fellowship which in our
case means something like an NLM
fellowship or VA you or it turns out as
we found out they were accepting of
having a masters
and you are board certified in a primary
specialty then you can become board
eligible so that's how those of us who
took the test last year weibull to pass
it now this it's good I think for those
of us in in the field who are positions
that there's this pathway but it
actually creates challenges things
because it's a sub-specialty of these
different specialties that there's a
paper by Don detmer who some of you know
in JAMA earlier this year just about
some of the fragmentation issues also
the funding issues the typical approach
as as most of you know when one is a
resident or a fellow in a clinical
setting is that you get paid in part
because you're contributing to the
clinical mission and you could certainly
argue that clinical informatics fellows
are contributing to the clinical mission
I mean hopefully our fellows will be
contributing to ohs use mission but they
don't do things you can build for like
an internal medicine physician who sees
patients in the clinic or in the
hospital or a surgeon who does
procedures so there's all kind and then
also clinical all clinical training is
more around these rotations rather than
courses and so I've coined the term
which has gotten a little cash a about
fitting square pegs into round holes
another issue is that by requiring a two
year full-time fellowship for these
physicians is that we may choke off
career paths because many physicians
pursue informatics axially many
healthcare people not not just
physicians and informatics pursue
gravitate into informatics over the
course of their career and so by saying
that now you have to do a two-year on
the ground fellowship it's difficult to
do that if you're you know 45 years old
and have a job and a family and so forth
which our distance learning program
actually been a nice alternative for so
i think i think there's there there's
going to have to be some adjustment of
this along the way fortunately ohsu
hospital and clinics has stepped up and
agreed to fund the fellows the initial
fellows and also some from the VA will
they maintain that commitment there is
some requirement for actually
maintaining their practice but CMS which
is which funds a lot of fellowships has
all these rules about what fellows can
do fellows actually can't bill although
they can work in the clinic and see
patients and the attending physician can
bill and then of course we spend so much
time talking about these the fellowship
model stuff like that and of course
informatics is not only for physicians
and in fact a Mia is exploring
certification brothers and what that's
going to look like if you actually look
at the clinical informatics content
outline that was published it was
published in Jamie in 2009 and went in
with the American Board of Medical
Specialties proposal there's really not
much that's specific to positions it's
actually just a nice outline of all the
topics in clinical informatics actually
joan joan was a little bit involved in
that so it has a good stuff on people
and organizational issues in fact the
board exam actually used the unintended
consequences a few times so reflecting
jones impact on the field anyways it'll
be interesting to see what happens with
with all this when we look at starting
to certify other people in clinical
informatics or even other areas of
informatics it's probably going to get
messy okay so that's just my kind of
high-level overview state of the field I
know I didn't cover everything and I
probably focused in in some areas more
than others but I only have an hour to
do this whole talk and I want to leave
time
question so let me just make a few
comments about the state of the program
which i think is very good running
academic programs is never not
challenging pardon the double negative
but you know with budgets and and NIH
grant funding leveling off and actually
all of the interest in informatics has
spawned a lot of competitors who have
seen how successful we've been and other
programs have been in informatics and
they're now trying to emulate us and so
but our research programs are doing well
are were undertaking other new
innovations such as the informatics
discovery lab which most you know about
and I'll make a few comments about and
our educational programs are doing well
we had that large infusion of money from
the HITECH Act which are vastly
increased our number of students mostly
in the distance program but because it
was stimulus money that money ended and
we kind of come back down to pretty much
where we were before our existing tracks
are doing well our new programs are
developing and also something that is of
interest it's being led by the physician
side of the field but again it's not
really limited to physicians is being
involved in informatics education for
clinicians and others so I apologize to
the faculty if your name isn't on this
list but I always keep a slide of all of
our research expertise it's basically
the whole field and I try to put names
but anyways just all of the different
areas where we have expertise I mean we
are certainly one of the broadest fields
in informatics and even put in the
clinical epidemiology folks as well so
this is I'm not going to go through all
this but we have a lot of expertise
around here which is great for students
who are looking for projects and
I think it's something we should be
proud of so i'm gonna i'm going to toot
our horn and maybe my horn a little bit
here but some of you know Alison McCoy
who works with Dean siddig someone for a
different field had developed a way of
going through google scholar and
identifying all the people in a field
and what their h-index is and for those
of you who've never taken my information
retrieval course where you would learn
what h-index was it's basically a
measure of how many citations to your
work how many of your how many of your
papers have been cited that many times
and so we we're on the all-star list
here of all these people and I need to
get convinced the rest of some of the
other faculty to get on this list but
and over time the younger folks will
percolate up the h-index does kind of
correlate with years in the field so
that's why I Joan and I our highest but
but even youngsters i noticed that julie
managed to get herself but that's a
great start you know i'm confident your
number will grow and one of my projects
for this year is to get everyone to
create a google scholar profile so
you'll end up on this list somewhere so
if you and if you look through the list
there's plenty of ohsu representation
most of the other programs that we know
well are there also i myself have been
involved in some new projects and my new
collaborator a new adjunct faculty
member steven woo is is here also who
brings expertise and a connection to the
Mayo Clinic or text processing work and
I like to lump this project in with all
of our recent Big Data funding we're
actually going to be creating a corpus
of a hundred thousand patient records
five million actual records or documents
of and then apply it to one specific
task
though certainly there is opportunities
to apply to other tasks but apply to a
specific task of cohort identification
identifying people who are potential
candidates for clinical studies and and
some of you I've talked here before
about the trek medical records track
it's a it's an extension of that but to
me this is exciting not only because
it's a new grant a new project but and
also for the first time gets us working
with large amounts of data and and all
the issues because this is data with the
pH I with protected health information
so it needs to be kept very secure and
needs IRB approval for everything in
anything you do with it but but this is
exciting to probably Erin will talk more
about the informatics discovery lab in
another talk but this is a really
important initiative for the program for
variety of reasons and it's not being
driven solely by economics but certainly
as grant funding gets tighter academic
departments need to look to other
sources to maintain the work they do but
but i think the real more important
aspect of it is that it gives us an
opportunity for to move our work out
into the real world to make it more
relevant we're really good in academia
coming up with new ideas and getting
them to work and writing about them and
then they may just sit there but now
we'll have an opportunity to push things
out we have a number of ongoing
discussions with some companies some
some that you've heard of and will be
interacting with them in different ways
and and one of the first projects out of
this which most of you know about is our
partnership with epic which is the first
time that epic has actually
agreed to do informatics work with with
the program epic has no troubles with
doing with having people user system for
capturing patient data for research and
things like that but actually doing
informatics work and both using epic in
in our courses the new version of 513
that Vishnu teaches and also looking at
it for research so so I think this is
going to become a big a big activity of
the department going forward our
educational programs are doing well I
actually probably need to update this
map because it's a couple years old but
that just represents dots of where our
distance learning students live and one
of these days I'm going to overlay that
where we're all the other great
informatics programs are and show that
we have a presence in those towns as
well we now have six hundred and five
degrees and certificates awarded to 558
individuals so we have a very large
alumni base we also have people who can
it come back for more we're one of the
14 LM funded fellowship programs are
Fogerty grant with argentina's
unfortunately coming to an end and it's
not clear that they're going to continue
that program we also get fellowship
funding from the VA and we're also known
for our innovations including the ten by
ten program of which Don Denver once
said is the most successful initiative
that amy has ever undertaken really
started in 2005 when a mia wanted to get
into online learning and we actually had
BMI 510 and it was really essentially
BMI 510 becoming this thing called 10 by
10 that was edit its goal 10,000 trained
by 2010 we actually had about a thousand
people do it by 2010 but because the
interest was so much we've continued it
and there's now about 1,800 people who
have done 10 by 10 and probably about
fifteen or twenty percent of them have
subsequently enrolled in our
graduate program mostly in the online
program though some of them came and
some of them have even when did their
way up all the way to our PhD program
dr. McCormick back there and so we're
known for these sorts of things that and
and another I mentioned before that our
our clinical informatics fellowship for
position has been accredited and there
we're actually going to be playing
innovative roles as well for example
some of the other places that have
launched clinical informatics
fellowships are actually going to be
using our online courses for their
fellow so some of you know Chris
longhurst from Packard Children's
Hospital at Stanford so he's launched
the Stanford clinical informatics
fellowship that was actually the first
one that was accredited and their
fellows are taking a HS you courses I
had them in my 510 course over the
summer and now Vishnu has them and
others of you will get to know them as
well and there's other programs that are
planning to do that so that's another
way that we we can contribute another
area that that's been a great interest
to me is informatics for clinicians we
really won't be successful in
informatics if everything is just us
doing informatics and even though
today's medical students come in very
savvy with their phones and they you
know know how to type a few words into
Google they don't know informatics and
there's a lot to learn to be a 21st
century physician or really any kind of
clinician about informatics to finding
the right information using an
electronic health record well being
involved in clinical decision support
quality measurement telemedicine things
like that so ohsu so I actually started
advocating this at ohsu about 1995
or so I've been here five years still in
the system professor and people would
always see that's a good idea but you
know not in my course not in my course
and in in fact it was probably that
probably was a boon to the graduate
program because we've never had any
resistance and in developing our
graduate program because no one around
here really competes with us but in the
medical school curriculum you compete
with surgery and anatomy and pediatrics
and everyone else for for real estate in
the medical school curriculum but we
have a new senior associate dean George
Makano some of you know him and we also
have a like every medical school goes
through a curriculum revision like every
10 or 15 years so we're doing that now
we also got funded by this grant from
the AMA which historically hasn't really
been interested in medical education but
they're more interested now and so all
of these factors have sort of formed
this kind of critical mass and our focus
has really been on trying to develop
competencies for what students need to
do in informatics and again not just you
know being able to navigate through
their smartphone but really the kinds of
things we do so I know you probably
can't read this but we actually
published this paper that has actually
gotten a lot of interest about this
competency set that we developed for
well although it's for medical students
but pretty much everything here is
Jermaine to any anyone who's a clinical
student using electronic health record
searching clinical decision support
understanding health information
exchange quality measurement patient
engagement through personal health
records and patient portals things like
that all these things are going to
impact clinicians in the 21st century
and we're actually developing curricula
for medical students that will teach
them these sorts of things
so okay well it's good i finished about
when i wanted to because i want to leave
some time for her comments but the just
kind of in conclusion so things are
going well but there are continued
challenges everything from the current
state of our clinical systems our
electronic health records being
suboptimal to the challenges of research
funding and our educational programs
keeping up with the field sometimes in
some fields educational programs kind of
lag behind where the field is but i
don't think that's the case with us in
any of the tracks informatics is still
the place to be so it's the area where
we can do good work and make a career
out of it and feel good about what we're
doing contribute to people's health to
the health care system and and research
so i will stop at that point and open up
the floor to questions let me just
remind people because we record this and
there's people listening to push the
little button and hold it down on the
microphone or if people are listening
out there in cyberspace to send us by
twitter is there anything on the twitter
feed yeah okay any other comments yeah
it's james thank you um the simulation
lab that we all get a tour of the other
night what initiatives are we working on
with the sim lab and how might that be
expanded yeah great question and and on
my list of the gazillion things that our
faculty does simulation is listed in
there there's an interesting story
behind that Jeff gold has become the
leader in that area and vishnu 'he's
working with him right when we got the
first when we got the ONC funding Jeff I
don't know read about it somewhere and
came and said you know I've got all of
these critical care fellows who miss
things in plain sight in epic taking
care of patients
you know what can I do about it so I
said well you know let's let's try to
document it and and we actually did a
little study that was published and then
he got interested in that area some
funding opportunities came along and all
of a sudden our EHR simulation program
was built and so Jeff is also involved
in the curriculum with the medical
students so obviously if you're going to
simulate the clinical environment part
of that environment includes the
electronic health record and all the
data and and that's very much a part of
that simulation center which if you
toured it you saw you know well I mean
there's actually some interesting
informatics just around simulation
itself but all of the rooms have
computers the even the out patient rooms
have the computers that are hanging
there so everything from teaching people
the best way to use a computer in exam
room so there's lots of involvement with
with us and that any other questions
Oh what the heck the little question why
there's so much you know focus on the
clinical informatics fellowship but you
mentioned a little bit about Amyas
desire to certify other practitioners it
seems that the majority of clinical
practitioners and informatics won't in
the long run fit into that little bucket
of people who can do clinical fellowship
so the actual population of people who
will probably be needed in the field and
working won't fall into that so do you
have anything else you could say about
that yeah well the soap want one of the
downsides to kind of going the medical
sub specialty route is that that means
you have to have a medical subset you
have to have a medical specialty I
actually luck out lucked out in this
regard in that I got certified in
internal medicine at a time when people
got lifetime certifications you know you
pass the board exam you're certified for
life even though we have to do
continuing education and all that but
that's all changed in medicine and so
people need to keep up their clinical
side and it can be difficult especially
like if you're in primary care so so one
group of physicians who are kind of left
out well there's physicians are a number
of positions are left out of this
process because either they're not
certified or they discover informatics
in the middle of their career and then
of course again informatics not only
about physicians so there's all these
other people so it's going to be
interesting to see what comes out of
this amia process you know another issue
is do you do people need to be certified
in informatics you know one form one way
that people get certified in a career is
that they get a credential like a degree
a master's degree a PhD health care
though has always been this
sort of certification oriented and this
did this isn't medicine I mean this is
nursing and pharmacy and physical
therapy and everything else so it'll be
interesting to see what kind of
certification process develops and what
kind of training requirements there will
be for it because it's going to be you
know they call it the advanced
interprofessional informatics
certification so it's going to be many
different professions so I don't imagine
that they're actually going to be able
to prescribe certain fellowships because
it just might not work for nurses or
physical therapists or whoever so it
remains to be seen what that's going to
be it also remains to be seen how
important it's going to be to have that
clinical informatics certification
credential are someone not going to hire
you because you don't have it you know
what if you have other advanced training
and informatics or experience and so
forth so I you know I think there's I
think there's a lot of unanswered
questions and I think we'll we'll see
over time how it all plays out you know
their other you know the the previous
last new medical specialty was emergency
medicine because people they're never
people worked in emergency departments
but they were internists and surgeons
and anesthesiologists it took a while
for it to be certainly in urban areas to
be required to be an emergency physician
and even in some areas there just aren't
emergency position so we'll see yeah my
bill I think in academic departments
we've got research missions and teaching
missions and an operational missions and
I'm curious about for the people that
you're seeing now who are interested in
the informatics clinical informatics
sub-specialty are you seeing them
cluster into any of those areas for what
they want to be when they grow up
because I'm curious what you're seeing
and also how that impacts that
actually a fish department DBS drifting
toward one or the other because of that
yeah they're mostly mostly people who
interested in operational areas because
like if you look at departments if you
look at clinical departments in medical
schools like a department of
ophthalmology I mean all of you guys are
certified in ophthalmology you know to
do your ophthalmology practice and
whereas the academic the academic work
that you do you're not really certified
per se you know you have your formal
informatics training but so its
certification is typically more sort of
fitness to perform in some sort of
operational role so for that reason a
lot of the you know initial cohort of
people certified our chief medical
informatics officers and things like
that and then some academics like us who
make sure that we want to get certified
because we want to run programs or
otherwise get recognized for what we do
but but the large majority are
interested in operational roles and
academic informatics always has this
kind of challenging relationship with
kind of service versus academia you know
we're we're not the IT department we
actually shouldn't be the IT department
we can help the IT department but you
know I think that there's always this
kind of tension between how much you
know sometimes that we get invited to
collaborate on grant proposals because
they basically think we're the IT person
and that often doesn't work out well but
it's a challenge and this is actually
challenged in the bioinformatics world
to how much you know knowledge and
scientific work do you bring to the
project you know as opposed to being the
kind of you know person who keeps the
software up and running
okay well and let me ask dev one last
time if there's any incoming cost of
Twitter feed it we when we first started
doing it we got a lot more comments but
we have you and now okay well thank you
all for for listening and I appreciate
you coming and we have a number of other
interesting speakers plans starting
tomorrow Andre crush nick is an expert
in usability which is another important
area in the field so thank you